[Music]
it seems to me that's the main strategy
in your life is its capping downside so
it's like okay you put $50,000 into
startup the most you can lose is fifty
thousand you spend five hundred thousand
dollars on a real estate investment
you're responsible for the cost of
maintaining the property you know like
it's a it's a totally different and so
and I think that that explains your
experiment thing so it's not I'm
starting a podcast now I have to have a
podcast forever you're thinking I'm
committing to six so the most if I don't
like it the most I have to do is six
episodes of something I don't like yeah
do you know what I mean you're you're
capping you're capping so it's not
endless amounts of losses whether that's
time resources happiness money yeah and
I always try to cultivate walk away
power with my own projects how do you do
that
I'll explain or try to explain why I
think it's important first if if I feel
like I have to do something you lose
your optionality you haven't and
furthermore you begin to make decisions
out of fear or guilt which in my
experience turn out almost always turn
out poorly yeah similarly if you're
making decisions at a prestige can turn
April I think I borrowed that from Maria
Popova and what she said once on the pot
on the podcast but cultivating walkaway
power is a function for me of a
revisiting how little you actually need
very quickly yeah this is Seneca yeah
Seneca not tea Moore's poppers hot spit
you know I will set aside a certain
number of days each month or whatever it
is to get by with the scan tiss scan
toaster scanty estai always mess that up
affair but practicing periods of poverty
or
it's like knowing being okay with the
rock-bottom yeah making a making dude I
just did this last week I'm making do
for a while it's like instant coffee and
like oatmeal and a bag that you cook
we have boiling water yeah and
everything's great and granted it's
different when you do it for an extended
period time it's different if that's
your only option nonetheless constantly
revisiting it and confirming how little
is actually needed is number one number
two is doing fear setting this exercise
and it talked quite a lot about which is
of course borrowed directly from
stoicism and cognitive behavioral
therapy which is also largely based on a
stoic philosophy of what is the term in
Latin it is meditating yeah yeah
meditation malorum meditating on the the
possible evils or risks so I have a
written format fear setting people can
check out teamed-up blog for slashed Ted
if you want to see what that looks like
it's all free I do that routinely so
we're recording this in January 2020 and
I did a lot of feature setting around
talking how poorly this conversation of
the writing could go and how I would
possibly repair their incredible
reputational damage around stopping just
about everything so even though I'm not
seriously considering or do I feel
compelled to say stop stopping the
podcast right I would write down like
stop the podcast question mark what if I
stopped this what if I stopped at all
involvement with real estate what if I
stopped all travel sure what if I
stopped and now I will go through the
thought experiment of what if I
completely stop these various things
categorically and when you run through
the kind of so what so what so what so
what each of those ultimately realize
you're gonna be [ __ ] fine yeah with
all of them sure and to that extent I
think that
making good decisions is often
negotiating with yourself and that the
person you want to have win that
negotiation and this is advice I got a
long time ago is the person who cares
the least and that's not a value
judgment but if you have two people
negotiating against each other and one
feels like they have to do the deal yeah
and the other person has a has 20
different batas right best alternative
to a negotiated agreement and they don't
give two shits whether the deal happens
or not or at the very least they're very
comfortable walking away yeah he or she
who cares the least wins yeah and I like
to cultivate the side of me that can see
how little a lot of the glossy veneer
aspects of life add at the end of the
day to like the core of what you need to
feel content on a regular basis so that
might be a lot of word salad at once but
the those are at least some of the ways
that I think about it no I think that
ties into we were just talking about the
Stokes Marcus Aurelius has this thing he
says like ask yourself at every moment
is this necessary like what you're
thinking what you're doing what you're
desiring is this necessary
and that seems you just have a sign in
ur house that said like simplify still
have it yeah is that seems like you guys
are in alignment you're like how do I
need this do I want this what would
happen if I didn't have it
why does everyone else want it it seems
like you're constantly questioning that
you